hey guys i'm lisa foiles welcome to
analog on this weekly show I suggest
similar games to the ones you already
love and conveniently if you need to
hear one of my suggestions again you
simply rewind and re-watch well today
we're covering a game that also lets you
do that it's super time for the xbox
live arcade and xbox one side-scrolling
shooter with a very laid-back attitude
towards screwing with history if quests
like retrieving the Holy Grail in order
to save a line of medieval chain
restaurants left you wanting more then
here are three games similar to super
tank force
the moment I saw that digital clock
relentlessly counting down at the top of
the screen and super time force I
thought of half minute hero does the
overwhelming length of RPGs get you down
how about an RPG that requires you to
save the world in 30 seconds like super
time force this game features
retro-inspired graphics is extremely
fast-paced and revolves around time but
with added RPG elements this game keeps
itself light-hearted by actually making
fun of traditional RPGs for example if
you select know when the time goddess
offers to help you she goes that's fine
but what other RPG left to advance by
selecting no and then you have disliked
yet speaking of the time goddess she
allows you to rewind the clock when 30
seconds is just not enough time to get
through your stage there are four
different storylines with four different
types of game play hero 30 is a high
speed RPG princess 30 is a classic
shooter evil lord 30s RTS and 930 is
simple action as you protect an escort a
sage like super time force battling is
great but managing your time is the
source of the games fun super time
horses time rewind mechanic is brilliant
but we've seen it before so if you
haven't played braid you better pause
everything while super time force has
gun through the level and don't look
back braid makes you slow down
reconsider your movements and your
motive this game is less 8-bit and more
artsy and is surprisingly serious in
fact the true meaning of the game's
story is still debated the two games are
nearly identical in their rewind or ctrl
Z mechanic if you screw up you can
quickly undo with the click of a button
and try again without restarting from a
checkpoint this isn't just for killing
enemies it's mandatory for solving crazy
difficult puzzles this is a game for
thinkers and perfectionist some puzzles
make you go through a motion rewind time
create a clone or shadow of Tim then go
through a new motion to solve the puzzle
with you and yourself yes just like
super time force but sadly instead of
rescuing the clone and collecting its
essence you heartlessly sacrifice shadow
Tim for your own agenda jerk alright
maybe you like manipulating time in your
video game but you aren't keen on the
cutesy graphics maybe you need more
exploring in beautiful environments
let's go 3d with Prince
persia sands a time if Aladdin and
spider-man saw had a baby it would be
the young cocky prince of persia he's
tricked into releasing the sands of time
and must right his wrong with the help
of beautiful Farah thankfully the prince
is so acrobatic they're running along
walls and bouncing off the heads of
enemies is a piece of cake it's made
especially easier when you have yes a
redo button the dagger of time lets you
rewind and try again if you fall off a
ledge or get killed by an enemy this is
awesome for a 3d game since we all know
that reloading a level from the
beginning or even just from a checkpoint
can take forever while the previously
suggested games revolve around the time
manipulating mechanic here is simply
implemented into a game that almost
doesn't need it yet it's incredibly
helpful when you do use it the dagger
also lets you freeze enemies and slow
down time but it's not a crutch the
combat is still fluent the acrobatics
are intuitive and the characters are
heroic on their own but forget Farah the
prince of persia needs to get together
lark rock and spawn a super protagonist
who could also be on our olympic
gymnastics team you did blinks the time
sweeper is another game you could check
out but only if you like time-traveling
cats which you should leave a comment
with your thoughts tweet me at lisa
foiles and i'll see you next time for
another analog